today on the matt well show is it even
possible to be a police officer in
america today when even shooting a
knife-wielding suspected rapist and
serial abuser causes protests and riots
also five headlines including the
apparent execution murder of a trump
supporter in portland
and joe biden's incredible moral
cowardice in the face of
this escalating violence and our daily
cancellation we will cancel the latest
celebrity to come out as
non-binary whatever that's supposed to
mean exactly that and much more to
discuss today a lot coming up but first
let's talk about legacy box cue the
background music
very relaxing now um listen i don't know
about you but i have uh
i have some of my favorite old family
memories trapped in old camcorder tapes
and videos and other
decaying forms of old media in fact just
a few days ago my mom gave me a box of
my old stuff some old pictures and
videos and stuff
uh memories and i kind of wondered why
she didn't want to keep them for herself
i guess i'm being disowned i don't know
but anyway that's all the more reason to
use
legacy box legacy box is a super simple
mail and service to have all of your
video tapes
camcorder tapes film reels pictures um
digitally preserved on a thumb drive dvd
or the cloud
with summertime officially coming to an
end we've got fall on the brain
uh what were your favorite fall
childhood memories maybe apple picking
carving pumpkins football games
watching the leaves change whatever it
is did your parents
capture these memories on camera are
these recorded moments still you know
trapped on outdated
videotapes film reels slides uh being
able to preserve those memories is
exactly what
legacy box was created to do let them
digitally preserve your past and bring
new life to those trapped
family memories um i can tell you you
know i got my first legacy box back a
couple of months ago it was a big treat
a lot of fun
very simple and easy to do on my end
anyway you know i don't know what magic
they pull over there but for me it was
very easy
and now um i'm thinking i'll probably do
it again and i think you should too get
started preserving your pass today with
our
labor day sale go to legacybox.com walsh
to get 50 off your first order order
today
send in when you're ready um this
exclusive offer won't last long so go to
legacybox.com
walsh and save 50 off while supplies
last okay um here's the scenario
you are a police officer a seven-year
veteran of the force
one day a call comes in domestic
disturbance
a woman is contacted 911 because her
ex-boyfriend is at her house
is not supposed to be there she's scared
he's stolen her keys
wants to take her vehicle uh he's wanted
for sexual assault and domestic abuse
there's a warrant for his arrest when
you pull up in your police cruiser
you quickly notice the knife in his hand
you try to de-escalate the situation
with words reasoning with him
he's in no mood to be reasoned with then
you try to take control of the situation
physically but he fights back puts you
in a headlock
you deploy your taser it has no effect
another taser again no effect
then he starts moving towards the
vehicle is it going to grab a gun
is he going to steal the car and drive
away is he going to take it and run
you or the woman over there are kids
inside
will they become hostages will they get
injured in a car chase well he killed
them
these possibilities all race through
your head in the span of five seconds
maybe less
you don't have time to deliberate the
man has made his choice
and all you can do is respond to it so
you yell for him to stop he doesn't
listen
you yell again your gun is pointed right
at him he doesn't care
he opens the door you grab him he makes
a move to climb inside or reach for
something you're out of time
you shoot let's try another scenario
you're not a police officer in fact you
don't have any job at all
nor do you have a car sometimes you take
your ex-girlfriends without permission
one morning you're angry at her so you
break into her house
while she's sleeping you go into a room
and you sexually assault her just to
make a point
she's scared she's crying you've seen
her like this before
all the other times that you've abused
and beaten her through the years usually
when you're drinking
you leave her like that you exit the
room you steal her keys and her debit
card you drive away in her vehicle
you stop at the atm and take out some
money on her card
she calls the cops eventually a warrant
is issued for your arrest
fast forward a month or two you go to
her house again she tells you to leave
you refuse
you take her keys from her at some point
you draw a knife
the cops show up you assault them too
you refuse to go with them even after
two zaps from the taser you escape their
grasp
you start moving towards the car they
draw their guns point them at you
screaming you keep moving you open the
door
one officer is pulling at your shirt you
keep moving
you wake up in a hospital bed you cannot
feel your legs
now those are the two scenarios
two people same situation which of these
people did you find most
relatable whose actions can you more
readily
understand who made choices that you
could see yourself possibly making in a
similar situation
if you had to launch a moral or logical
defense of either person
which would you choose now far be it for
me to make assumptions about you but i
would certainly
hope and guess that you can relate to
defend and understand the first man the
police officer
the second man has his reasons i guess
for the way he acts but they cannot
possibly be good reasons
and his behavior is not defensible or
for decent people
understandable on any level at all
and yet in this upside down world in
which we live it is the second man
who gains all of the sympathy it is his
name that's cried out in grief and
mourning
it is for him that every professional
sports league in the country speaks out
in solidarity
it is his name that ends up on the
murals and the poster boards and the
t-shirts
the other man's name the police officer
who made choices and behaved in a way
that every decent and rational human on
earth
if they were to stop to think about it
for two seconds would at least find
comprehensible perhaps even admirable
is anathema he is cast in the role of
villain
the dastardly foil to our hero who also
happens to be a serial abuser and rapist
at least if the allegations are true now
granted
some of this scenario as i have
described it here is technically
speculative
but it's a scenario that emerges very
clearly from a combination of the video
the police scanner audio the criminal
complaint
complaint filed against jacob blake
stemming from his alleged
sexual assault of his ex-girlfriend in
may of this year and the testimony of
the kenosha police union
the other scenario the first one we were
given and the one that the media would
still like for us to believe that
blake is a family man and a good
samaritan randomly gunned down by a
racist cop for the crime of
breaking up a fight between two women
has absolutely no credible evidence of
any kind to support it
all of the evidence points to what i
have just described
and the allegation of the sexual assault
is just that an allegation but it was
made by a woman
who called 9-1-1 on the day of the
alleged crime and trembled with fear as
she recounted what had happened to her
there is just no good reason to doubt
her
um the point is that
from everything we know and in light of
all of the credible evidence
and i am counting by the way i'm
counting as decidedly not credible
the supposed eyewitnesses who initially
claimed that blake wasn't behaving
aggressively at all
even though he had a knife and he had a
cop and a headlock and only took his
girlfriend's keys and went to her car
with guns trained on him so he could
check on his kids that's what one of the
one of the eyewitnesses said so i'm i am
counting that is not credible but in
light of all the credible evidence
the police officers were responding to a
situation
entirely of jacob blake's own making and
doing what they could to protect all of
the innocent lives involved including
their own
there is a disjuncture no reasonably
plausible version of the story that
vindicates jacob blake and yet again
he is lionized and canonized and mourned
over
while the officers are castigated as
attempted murderers and racists
and those accusations rain down from
some of the most visible and powerful
perches in society in other words
it's the same old story playing out
again and again
and again and again how is it even
possible
to be a police officer in this
environment
because the moment a suspect a non-white
suspect resists arrest or goes for a gun
or tries to kill you or someone else
you lose no matter what you go to work
every day
to serve communities that despise you
you risk your life for people who
wouldn't dump a bucket of water on you
to put out the flames if you were on
fire in fact they probably set the fire
in the most intense and life-threatening
situations you are left with
no room for error even if you don't make
an error
the video that somebody captures and
cuts and clips and posts online
may make it seem like you did if you end
up in a fight for your life against a
violent sociopath
you may you may go to prison for winning
it
the people gathered around to watch and
film the incident will almost certainly
lie about what happened
they will inexplicably defend the
sociopath and call for your head on a
platter
they will say that they live in fear for
their life every day because of you
but it's the sociopath and people like
him who are responsible for almost
all of the killing and violence in their
community and yet its members will
choose him
over you like the crowds shouting for
pilate to release barabbas
and if he dies they will mourn the loss
of a man whose absence makes them all
safer
this attitude is not confined to any
town or city it's fostered at the
highest levels of society
powerful politicians and athletes and
celebrities are all dedicated to a
narrative
that is completely disconnected from
reality and if you're a police officer
they tell
lies about you and your line of work
constantly and they don't care if those
lies get you killed
and while your worst and most difficult
moments are broadcast to the entire
world and dissected by idiots and
charlatans who've never in their lives
faced a situation as volatile
as the kind you encounter every day your
triumphs are ignored
for example law enforcement law
enforcement officers in georgia just
completed a two-week operation that
successfully recovered 39 missing
children 15 of whom were being sex
trafficked
this news was you know covered in a
perfunctory way because it had to be but
it was not plastered all over the
headlines or shouted from the rooftops
only your mistakes or things that can be
made to look like
mistakes get that kind of treatment
it seems impossible to deal with this
and yet
thousands of police officers do deal
with it every day by choice
this doesn't mean that police officers
are always right or that injustice at
the hands of law enforcement never
happens
or that we should adopt an uncritical
attitude towards agents of the state far
from it
but they are doing a job that society
needs done
and one that is only made more difficult
by the day
so i figure i owe them the respect of at
least
listening to their side of the story and
trying to see it from their perspective
and considering all of the factors in
the entire context before labeling them
bullies or murderers
for the choices they make in situations
i have never encountered
while doing a job i rely on but would
never
want to do myself especially these days
let's go to five headlines
[Music]
well we begin of course with the trump
supporter in portland apparently
executed at cold blood on sunday um
saturday that is a caravan of trump
supporters and blue lives matter
supporters went into portland to counter
demonstrate
much has been made of the fact that they
were uh shooting paintballs at the blm
and antifa people using pepper spray in
some cases and that's true
but every video i've seen of the
paintball and pepper spray being
deployed
begins with someone in the antifa slash
blm crowd throwing something at them or
using some other weapon against them
so in any case it was a volatile
environment
and then the shooting the victim's name
is aaron danielson the man
police are investigating for the killing
is michael forrest reinel
um a few pieces of footage have emerged
from this none of them very clear
the first shows you know in the distance
in the dark one man walk up to another
and then you see the gun go off and the
guy who pulled the trigger runs in the
other direction
it does not appear at all to be
self-defense in that video
it appears to be execution plain and
simple but the most
revealing video is actually one that
doesn't doesn't show the shooting at all
um instead it's what you hear that
matters i'm going to play that for you
now and uh
again you're not going to be able to
really see anything it doesn't matter
what you see
just just listen listen for the words
that you heard
[Music]
yeah that is one of the most chilling
videos i've ever seen and it doesn't
even
show uh the shooting itself you can
clearly hear someone say hey we've got
another one here
we've got another one we we got another
one here we've got someone right here
and then and then someone else says
right here and then bang bang you hear
the guns um
by all indications they targeted this
man
and executed him in cold blood
first-degree murder and political
terrorism
um and you know the guy who did it
should be should be
this should be federal charges ship them
off to guantanamo bay as far as i'm
concerned
he is not only a murderer but a
terrorist this is an act of terrorism
now needless to say the the leftists who
are apoplectic about kyle rittenhouse
in spite of the fact that it appeared in
his case to actually be self-defense
they couldn't find it in themselves to
condemn this this political execution
with nearly the same fervor or or really
condemn it at all in a lot of cases
um this includes of course the rotting
cucumber of a mayor ted wheeler
who spent more time in his press
conference yesterday condemning
donald trump than the actual guy who
pulled the trigger
and also joe biden who issued a
statement that really flies in the face
of all the stuff
we hear about him being a decent guy
just a wonderful guy the
the democrat convention it was just four
days of what a wonderful great guy he is
what here are
his his favorite ice cream toppings what
a great guy he is
um well you see not just in this but you
see
uh illustrated in this statement which
i'll read to in a second
the fact that joe biden is among other
things
an incredible moral coward so let me
play this for or not play it uh let me
read it for you in fact
here's the statement from joe biden
uh this statement by the way of course
is being praised by the media as being
just a wonderful wonderful statement
very calming and and all of that
great leadership here well you tell me
what you think
the deadly violence we saw overnight in
portland is unacceptable
shooting in the streets of a great
american city is unacceptable oh he
called it well it's unacceptable
great okay well that's a strong
condemnation isn't it
yes um uh walking up to a guy and
executing him on the street is
unacceptable
i condemn this violence unequivocally i
condemn violence of every kind by anyone
whether on the left or right
and i challenge donald trump to do the
same it does not matter if you find the
political views of your opponents
abhorrent
any loss of life is a tragedy today
there is another family grieving in
america and jill and i offer our dubious
condolences
we must not become a country at war with
ourselves a country that accepts the
killing of fellow americans who do not
agree with you
a country that vows vengeance towards
one another but this is the america that
president trump wants us to be the
america he believes we are as a country
we must condemn the incitement of hate
and resentment that led to this deadly
clash
listen to that part let me read it again
as a country we must condemn the
incitement of hate and resentment that
led to this
deadly clash it is not a peaceful
protest when you go out spoiling for a
fight
who does president trump what does
president trump think will happen when
he continues to insist on fanning the
flames of hate and division in our
society
and using the politics of fear to whip
up his supporters he is recklessly
encouraging the violence
uh and then he goes on a little bit more
uh attack just the rest of it is just
attacking president trump okay so
he spends most of this um condemning
president trump
there there i i don't i don't think
there is even in this statement really
a clear and very specific and harsh
condemnation of the killing itself
he calls it unacceptable but he does it
in the he's using a passive voice
which is a common trick that leftists
are pulling now and we'll get we'll get
to another example of that in just a
second
but he's using a passive voice and he's
kind of speaking in general
oh deadly a clash a deadly clash this
wasn't a clash
it wasn't a dead the deadly moment was
not a clash this was just a guy walking
on the street he was shot in the head
uh it's not a clash that's that's murder
and uh and but he's condemning the
incitement and hate and resentment that
led to this
now yeah i agree that there's a lot of
incitement and hate and resentment
leading to this
but that's happening from blm in antifa
and and democrats and i know that you
know
i basically just said the same thing
three times sorry for the redundancy
that's happening from them but that's
not what he means he's saying the people
that were there
were inciting the hatred and and uh
and and resentment so this is this is
victim blaming on top of it
um at a minimum this is moral cowardice
from joe biden
who just i'm sorry is not the great
decent guy
uh that they make him out to be i wish
he was
i really wish he was but he's not
um number two since we're on the subject
of the impossibility of policing these
days here are a few exhibits to present
for your consideration
uh not that you need any more we've seen
a lot but just some some of the latest
okay on that topic first this is a blm
leader in dc
openly calling for police and other
public officials to be murdered
and this is being said into a megaphone
in the middle of the city
um and uh anyway take a listen
i'm not the point where i'm ready to put
these police in the [ __ ] grave
[Music]
i'm at the point where i want to burn
the [ __ ] white house down
i want to take it to the senators i want
to take it to the congress
i want to take the fight to them and at
the end of the day
if they ain't going to hear us we burn
them
down
i'm one that talk real [ __ ] i'm talking
in new york
and i'm talking in dc
the same way i police up in new york i
cops up here in d.c
the same way i bust police in the head
in new york i bust police in the head of
d.c
[Music]
now it's a lot of people and i'm gonna
be honest
it's a lot of people that's on this
front line and one of the things that i
always say
don't give on this [ __ ] front line if
you ain't gonna [ __ ] fight
don't get on this front line if you
ain't gonna take no hit
don't get on this front line when the
police can push up you push back
if you won't be on this front line and
the racist
nasty punk [ __ ] police is pushing up
you push what you just heard there
um none of that is free speech that is
terrorism
incitement but you want to talk about
incitement that that's what incitement
sounds like
and if we didn't have such a feckless
and useless government
that person would have been arrested on
the spot and would be headed to federal
prison right now
again that is terrorism and then there's
this from cnn uh we talked about the
passive voice well here you go here's
their headline and caption on twitter it
says
two chicago police officers pulled over
a person suspected of having a gun
and all three ended up hospitalized with
gunshot wounds officials say
so all three ended up hospitalized how
did that happen
did bullets fall out of the sky randomly
how do they all end up with gunshot
wounds
what do you mean they ended up well it
turns out and you would have to read
like five or six
paragraphs into this article to see it
turns out the officers tried to pull the
guy over because he's committed
committing a crime allegedly and he shot
them both the suspect did
then a third police officer rushed into
the scene to save those officers and
shot
the suspect that's what happened but
even in the reporting
of a violent criminal shooting police
cnn
has to find a way to make it seem like
police at least share part of the blame
or maybe that no one is to blame
so enemy of the people yes these are the
cnn is these are
enemies of the people it's perhaps one
of the tr maybe the truest thing that
trump has ever said in his life
um describing the american media as an
enemy of the people
i mean they are they're trying to get
the american people many american people
killed
i mean they want to race war they want
violence and chaos and murder in the
street it's what they want i cannot
think of any other
way to explain this
i mean when you can't even bring
yourself to just just straight up report
violent criminal shoots police officers
you can't even do that
number three big shock over the weekend
uh another big shock as a weekend of a
lot of
shocking events none of them good
unfortunately um so another one it was
announced that chadwick boseman who
starred in black panther also played
jackie robinson james brown played a
he had quite a quite a filmography in a
relatively short career
he has died of cancer colon cancer
apparently he was diagnosed back in
i think it was 2018 and he never
i believe he never told anyone publicly
about his diagnosis
and he went on making movies and and
doing press visiting sick children in
hospital
you know carrying on being a public
figure a celebrity without ever letting
on that he was dying of cancer which is
a really remarkable
thing i think it's a great example of um
of courage
and dignity um and it reminds me of a
story when i when i read about this i
immediately thought of a story that i
think i've mentioned before in the gulag
archipelago soulja neeston's
book about the soviet um labor camp
system
and one story he tells a lot of stories
that really stick out but but one
in particular about um a guy who's
in one of these prison camps scheduled
to be executed
uh but he convinces the guards to let
his wife
visit so you can see his wife one last
time before he's killed
but the deal is that he's not allowed to
tell his wife
that he's going to be executed so he can
spend a couple days with her but he
can't tell her anything
and probably telling her would put her
own life in jeopardy so he spends a
weekend with her
you know and uh he never lets on and she
never suspects anything and then as soon
as she leaves they take him before the
firing squad
so this is you know a similar kind of
thing a man facing down his own
mortality experiencing presumably an
incredible amount of inner anguish and
grief
and fear and panic and everything yet
carrying on with dignity
and quiet resolve so heartbreaking but a
great example
um for us all
let's go number four
i regret to inform you my friends that
michelle obama
uh former first lady wealthy powerful
admired loved famous
is nonetheless oppressed and she's
oppressed by you
it turns out so you know shame on you
for oppressing someone who's 100 times
richer and more powerful than you
how dare you in a recent podcast the
former first lady according to the new
york post this is what she said
telling her tale of oppression she says
when i've been completely incognito
during the eight years in the white
house walking the dogs on the canal
people will come up and pet my dogs but
will not look me in the eye
they don't know it's me what white folks
don't understand is like
that it's it's like that is so telling
of how white america
views people who are not like them you
know we don't exist
and when we do exist we exist as a
threat and that's exhausting
what the white community doesn't
understand about being a person of color
in this nation is that there are daily
slights in our workplaces where people
talk over you or
people don't even see you and then later
on she says we were stopping to get ice
cream and i had told the secret service
to stand
back because we were trying to be normal
trying to go in when i'm just a black
woman i noticed that white people don't
even see me
i'm standing there with two black little
black girls another black female adult
they're in soccer uniforms and a white
woman cuts right in front of us
like she didn't even see us the girl
behind the counter almost took the order
and i had to stand up and was like well
i'm not going to cause a scene with
michelle obama
she continues so i stepped up and said i
don't know what that means
anyway she said i stepped up and said
excuse me uh you don't see us four
people standing right here
you just jumped in line obama said the
woman didn't apologize she never looked
me in the eye she didn't know it was me
all she saw was a black person or a
group of black people or maybe she
didn't even see that
because we were that invisible okay
you know perhaps it never has occurred
to michelle that actually she's in no
position
to tell other groups of people what they
do and don't understand she says this
about three times in this one
you know it's in in two minutes of
talking she's
about three times she's like what white
people don't understand what you white
people don't realize
it's pretty disturbing that this woman
and her husband
were in charge of the country
and had this attitude about
you know about a a vast majority of the
american population
based on this she has a very low opinion
of white people
and a you know white person cuts in
front of her immediately assumes it's
racist
so how the hell do you know what other
people are thinking or feeling michelle
how do you know who are you to go around
saying this
you have no freaking idea what other
people are doing or what their
motivations are
or what's going on in their head who are
you to assume that
she just paddles off you know a dozen
things that white people think and don't
think and do and don't do
she's doing exactly what she accuses
white people doing to her
by not letting them exist and be real
and be their own people and speak for
themselves no she's gonna speak for them
um the arrogance of that is just i mean
it's off the richter scale
it's one of the most arrogant people in
the country is michelle obama and i'm
not just saying that based on on only
this this is this is part of a pattern
with her meanwhile the traumatic
experiences that she recounts getting
cut you know cut in front of in line
people not being overly friendly
uh getting talked over that happens to
everyone michelle
that's a normal thing for people it
happens to me
it happens to every person on earth
that is an utterly normal part of life
for
everyone okay we all deal with that
all of us i could tell you stories of
having people cut in front of me in line
it's happened to me i guarantee you that
you know what i didn't do though i
didn't assume that the person doing it
was it was a bigot or i didn't make
these these
damning assumptions about their entire
life and existence and everything based
on that
i assume that they either just didn't
see me because they weren't paying
attention they're up in their own head
and it's nothing racial or bigoted at
all or worst case scenario i assume
that you know in this moment this
person's acting like kind of a jerk
doesn't mean that they're a horrible
person elsewhere
i've done it myself i bet you have too
michelle i bet there have been times
when you've cut in front of people
knowingly or unknowingly so we all deal
with that
okay all of us all of that stuff oh i
got talked over
that that happens to everyone it is so
normal i it's not we don't like it it's
not fun
it's annoying it is so normal though i i
i can't stress this enough it just
happens to everyone all the time it
really does i
promise you that and and rather than
making assumptions about entire races of
people
and telling white people what they do
and don't experience why don't you
ask them you know why don't you why
don't you let them speak for themselves
and tell you what they experience so
you have something that happens to you
every once in a while you get cut in
front of in line
someone talks over you rather than
assuming oh this never happens to any
anyone of that race maybe ask them oh
does this happen to you guys
and if they tell you yes then just take
them at their word
um but here's the deal michelle obama
you know she said she's pretending she
wants to be treated just like everybody
else no
she wants the opposite she doesn't want
she's offended that she was treated like
everybody else
she doesn't want that she's offended not
to be treated differently under the
guise of being of being offended that
she was treated differently that's what
this is really about that's what this is
always about
i mean with this with this kind of thing
um
okay so especially when it's a
privileged rich
powerful wealthy person claiming that
they're being oppressed
uh in 99 times out of a hundred
what they're really going to be offended
about when you get down into it is just
that
they you know god forbid got treated
like a normal person once
okay number five the vmas were last
night i somehow completely missed that
uh they were on i usually watch all the
vmas i'm a big fan of you know i host a
watch party
usually when the vmas are on we all wear
our pajamas and dance to the to the
songs
um it's a fun time in any case the
hollywood reporter has the recap
uh first of all there's a picture of
lady gaga accepting her award
for her performance in the latest power
rangers film it looks like she does look
she looks like a villain from power
rangers doesn't she a little bit or
maybe mortal kombat
um anyway the hollywood reporter says
kiki palmer hosted the show which aired
sunday night the weekend
won video of the year for blinding
lights at sundays actually it's spelt i
think it's misspelled because it's
missing an e for the weekend
it's really spelled weakened the weeknd
uh one video of the year other winners
sunday night included lady gaga and
ariana grande
bts taylor swift h-e-r maluma
machine gun kelly and megan the stallion
i don't know who any of these people are
i know taylor swift and lady gaga those
two i know uh grande she's the one who
licked the donut she's the donut
licorice i know her
h.e.r and maluma what
um these these
they sound like uh skin conditions a
little bit gaga's other wins included
artist of the year and song of the year
for rain on me her collaboration with
ariana grande
uh the weeknd also won best rmb
um kiki palmer host of the show blah
blah blah
i'm just see if there's any big okay
here we go later on in the show palmer
showed off her comedic chops by
portraying her alter egos including one
she's featured on her tick tock
while visiting different spots in new
york such as the bronx zoo where she
uh could see the quote the cats from the
whop video
i guess that's supposed to be a joke
that's her showing off her comedic shops
uh palmer encounters her southern belle
alter ego lady miss
at one point she jokes you're cattier
than carol baskin
oh man this is bad
you're cattier than carol baskin
that was actually a joke that made it
into this
professional production
oh man i i i you know i i went when i
was in seventh grade
my school had a talent show and there
was like an eleven-year-old who got up
and did a stand-up performance
and all of his material was way better
than your cattier than carol baskin so
unfortunately i i'm sad i missed that
show we all we all missed it um
you might say there are more important
things going on in the world i don't
know
like for example our daily cancellation
which we will get to now
sadly this afternoon i must cancel sarah
ramirez she is evidently an actress
best known for her role on grey's
anatomy the reason i have to cancel
sarah today is because of a recent post
on instagram where she
came out as non-binary now you might ask
what does coming out as non-binary mean
the answer is that it doesn't mean
anything because non-binary is not a
thing
unfortunately um there is a binary and
it's not possible to not be a part of it
the binary broadly speaking breaks down
like this okay
in one camp you have people who can get
pregnant
in the other camp you have people who
can get the people in the first camp
pregnant
pregnant
impregnator you might say not the most
eloquent way of putting it but that's
what it is
and there's your binary okay you can
call people in these camps whatever you
want call them team a
and team b you can make up some names
like i don't know snaggle spiffs and
gallywags
sounds a little bit like harry potter
characters but whatever or you know you
could even
use names like i don't know women and
men the name doesn't matter it's the
function and the biology that matters
yes i can already hear your objection
you are you are right now shouting i
know
you're saying what about women who can't
get pregnant huh
bet you never thought of them checkmate
loser
and then you take a sip of your kombucha
confident that you've just debunked
biology by pointing out that infertile
women exist
but you haven't i assure you infertile
women don't invalidate the statement
that women can get pregnant any more
than a man who loses an arm in a wood
chipper
accident invalidates the statement that
humans have two arms
his accident doesn't mean that humans
don't have two
arms or that we must now entertain the
possibility that there might be humans
out there with eight arms and 12 legs
and 46 heads
it just means he's supposed to have two
arms
but the wood chipper had other ideas
okay
in a similar way infertile women
are that way either because they're
older and their time of fertility has
passed or
because something went wrong illness
mutation deformity injury
surgery some known thing interceded
and deprived this woman of that function
but we know that she's supposed to have
it like the man with the one arm is
supposed to have two this is not a
problem for the binary
on the contrary this is what's known as
an exception that proves the rule
okay so that's the binary now
all of that said let's check in with
sarah ramirez reading from one of my
favorite
news organizations lgbtq nation uh it
says sarah ramirez the actor who played
the bisexual character cali torres on
the medical drama tv series
grey's anatomy came out as non-binary in
an august 27
instagram post the post which showed
ramirez with a crop top haircut was
captioned
new profile pic in me is the capacity to
be girlish boy boyish girl boyish boy
girlish girl
all neither hashtag non-binary
all right now hang on first of all it's
just a haircut relax
okay she she got a haircut now she
thinks she's a shape-shifter this is
like it's like if i spiked my hair up
and went
behold i am a transdimensional being
unbound by the laws of gravity i am god
look upon me and weep ye mortals you see
my hair cut
you can't get superpowers for 19 bucks
at sports clips is all i'm trying to say
okay anyway back to the article says
ramirez previously came out as bisexual
in october 2016 while making um
remarks at the true colors united's 40
to none summit
wait so she came out twice can you do
that she's is that a
well okay i guess it's a two different
thing non-binary bisexual uh back to the
article
this is at the time ramirez said and
because of the intersections that exist
in my own life woman
multiracial woman woman of color queer
bisexual mexican irish
american immigrant and raised by
families heavily rooted in catholicism
on both my mexican and irish sides
i am deeply invested in projects that
allow our youths voices to be heard
and that support our youth in owning
their own complex narratives
so that we can show up for them in the
ways they need us to
uh and says ramirez who has been married
to her husband ryan de debalt since 2011
is a member of the true colors fun board
of directors and blah blah blah okay
uh first of all you you notice how her
the intersections she lists are
completely redundant she lists women
three times
queer and bisexual is two different
things and multiracial and woman of
color has two separate things
and mexican and immigrant as twos
everything she's throwing 50-yard bombs
in garbage time basically she's padding
the stats okay
this is a person desperate to be seen as
interesting and different but like so
many people today
she's convinced that the only way to do
that is to get yourself into as many
demographic categories as possible
now if we were going to psychoanalyze
all of this
there are many directions we could go um
it would be a long and winding and
rather terrifying journey i suspect but
i want to focus on just this one thing
this this business about being
non-binary
as she says a boy a girl both and
neither
that of course makes no sense whatsoever
you cannot be something and be another
thing that's fundamentally different and
be both
and be none of them all at once you
might as well claim that you're standing
on the earth and the surface of the sun
at the same time
it is nonsensical objectively
but um what's going on here really
though
you know why do people make these claims
about themselves i think the answer or
part of the answer is this
sarah ramirez isn't so much observing
something about herself she is rather
making assumptions about other people
okay kind of like what michelle obama is
doing and i'll
explain more what i mean because it
strikes me that when when people do this
especially when celebrities
come out and say oh i am just so
complicated my inner life is so
interesting and unique my experiences
are so profound
i cannot be defined by the labels that
the rest of you use no no i
i am so many things and yet none of
those things i am like a work of
abstract art i am a walking poem
a song in the wind is my existence and
they go on and on and on
um and then they actually explain in
more detail what they mean
and why they have come to this
conclusion that they belong to a whole
new category of human existence
non-binary or whatever other label they
want when you listen to their
description of their inner experience
you think wait a second that's just
that's just being a person that's pretty
normal
the categories and labels and jargon are
different and bizarre and sound kind of
crazy but the actual experiences
underneath it
that's not special at all these people
are extraordinarily narcissistic
you have to understand especially
celebrities and so
they have normal human emotions and
experiences and assume
that the average person must not
experience any of this themselves
that they must be going through
something that is just far beyond the
emotional and psychological reaches of
the plebe on the street
they you know they they must be and they
must be making this assumption
otherwise how would they know that the
label of woman doesn't accurately
describe them
how do they know that all women don't
have the same sorts of emotions and
experience as they do
how do they know that what they're
feeling isn't just what women women feel
they assume that it's different and that
assumption
must be born at least in part by extreme
arrogance
so you're a woman with some
traditionally masculine interests and
tendencies
so what that's not special at all it
doesn't make you
not a woman that just makes you a woman
that's part of being a woman a person a
human
we don't need a new category for you it
doesn't make you a woman and a man and
none and all together
the most feminine women women in the
world have masculine aspects of their
personality my wife for instance very
feminine very good at traditionally
feminine things like decorating for
example but
if you pour her three fingers of 100
proof whiskey she'll guzzle that thing
straight no problem
she built her own barn for the chickens
i i helped in fairness but
still she knows how to bait a hook you
know i could go on
does that mean that she's not a woman
she's non-binary she's a man
a woman both and neither no she's just a
woman but but she's a woman with some
unique and interesting
traits and facets to her personality
indeed
what makes the thing about the whiskey
kind of funny and cool is precisely that
she's a woman
you know i can hold my liquor too but
nobody cares about that i'm a man it's
expected
what allows it to be different uh what
allows us to be different and develop
our own identity and personality are the
ways that we put our
own spin on the categories we naturally
belong to
in the same way we all belong to the
category of human being right
and because of that if any one of us
ever figures out how to fly without
mechanical assistance
that's going to be a pretty big deal if
we were birds
it wouldn't be and if you do ever start
flying
that wouldn't make you a bird if it did
then this utterly
fascinating gobsmacking thing about you
would suddenly be rote and routine
again what makes us interesting are the
variations within the categories
if you deny the categories or experience
variation and decide that it means that
you belong to the other category you
know you're a man who has feminine
tendencies in certain areas so you
decide that you are in fact a woman
if you do that then you actually lose
what made you interesting
you lose your uniqueness
gender is binary because of biology as i
explained at the beginning
nothing you can ever do or feel will
change that you are a man or a woman a
he or her you are not both
you are not one than the other you are
not neither you are not a they
um and it takes i suppose some measure
of basic humility to admit that and
submit yourself to that reality which
imposes itself on you whether you like
it or not anyway
but that doesn't mean you have to live a
cookie-cutter existence
or think and act just like everybody
else on your side of the binary
if you're a woman be whatever kind of
woman you want
wear whatever you want get whatever sort
of haircut you want
the high top fade on a woman doesn't do
much for me personally but hey it's your
head do what you want
live how you want think what you want
that's not to say that every choice we
make is going to be equally good healthy
and moral but the point is
simply that you have a lot of freedom as
a woman to be the sort of woman you want
to be
you just don't have the freedom to be
not a woman
and that's okay in fact there's a lot of
freedom in accepting that
but for now sarah ramirez does belong to
a new category of existence
an ever-growing category that would be
the category of cancelled
by me and that's it for the show
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there